so we're saying [ __ ] it dr. Dre yeah
Puff Daddy made a baby yeah
[Music]
purists might say that mixing different
beers together is blasphemy but if I've
learned anything in the last 23 years in
the brewing game it's that screwing with
tradition can actually be a good thing
when you try to do something special so
today I'm here at seamstress crap
cocktail bar on the Upper East Side with
a legendary MC Nora here to prove that
sometimes with beer if you add more
ingredients together much like with a
rap career it can be exponentially
awesome so it is true we are here to
party yes this drinks looking at me I'm
about to taste it right I heard about
Russian it no no I heard you you used to
drink a lot I used to drink IPAs I was a
real bad Gosselaar I still go to London
and you know Australia so much the IPAs
is IBA from like you're okay so so I
said drink it so much but started
drinking wine yeah this is my first time
I'm turning back to bed we're gonna get
you back because of you
baby steps this one's called liquid
truce here we can't help but tell the
truth when you drink this beer is that a
good thing or bad thing it's [ __ ]
fantastic
classic IPA this is what I want for my
IPA immediately as the flavors pause
circus in my mouth it's the strongest
flavor without it being like hardcore
liquor yeah yeah that and I'd say malt
liquor I don't [ __ ] up malt liquors I'm
sorry what the hood from the projects we
never it's not a great thing so we was
trying to stay away from what liquor at
this point has grown men on hot ones you
were talking a little bit about how st.
IDEs was a beer that really did a good
job of integrating the hip hop culture
and they did a whole series of ads with
awesome first gen you know legends they
did an ad with Biggie Smalls
wu-tang clan and at this time we in the
hood identified more with Budweiser
meaning Budweiser was the beer that our
fathers drinks and our grandfathers
drink saying eyes were smart enough to
say you know what hip-hop is the leading
culture of the world and to me that may
say eyes the illest company in the world
for recognizing our culture for decades
you've been in the game but you've
defined what the definition of the game
is from rap to your podcasts fake
journalism and now in the food yes
you've got a long long tradition of
mixing [ __ ] up yes I do so that's where
we're going next while we mix it we're
gonna mix some beers people have heard
of black and tan that's like you know
the Guinness and I'm kind of like normal
we're gonna mix two beers together and
make something totally new I am so ready
let's do it
Solow I imagine it's half of this and
half yes and that makes one drink is
that correct right so let me let me try
it some DIY [ __ ] let's do this what is
this call so this one sequential it's
got lime juice black lime sea salt in it
what I've never heard with this
combination continue and then this one's
lupa luau
coconuts and a coconut scented hop he's
my friend I really like this guy I
definitely don't know what he's trying
to do right now because I've never heard
of this type of mixture where I'm in we
call it lime in the coconut so let's try
this tell me I'm gonna fake it like ice
wine yeah how would you go through your
first sip of wine that you're super
psyched like a nice bottle of wine that
you bought what would your ritual be
before you take that this would be the
exact what you I'll pour it yeah I look
at the legs make sure the legs coming
down yeah there's no legs here yeah
it's beer I smell the first things smell
[Music]
the wine is fantastic so I want your
impressions on this one more sip and
then rate like I just want spontaneous
reaction of what you think of this okay
man with educators how first off we're
still yeah this is intoxicating yeah
soon as you smell it you smell like you
might play hooky like even though you
know you're not in school yeah you might
go day drinking yeah like it smells like
cookie
it smells like hooky at a school year
these are 21 years old
all right now I'm taste it again yeah
[Music]
great yeah the reason why it's greasy
because it's this bitter in the sour
taste together you you put it together
and it just works I couldn't say any
better than that
mm-hmm let's move on to the next button
I'm in now we're having the Brooklyn
Brown and the Sierra Nevada it's a nod
to traditional English mixture remix of
beers
black and tan but profile wise I wanted
to be like one of your favorites
Newcastle Brown these are two the og
American craft beer this is American
American look like first generations if
I could do like a little hip hop
comparison New York hip hop these these
guys were first West Coast these guys
were first
so we're saying [ __ ] dr. Dre I pumped
daddy made a big yeah let's do it
so I'm together Cheers let me know what
you thought now let's see yeah what do
you think it's a different glass but let
me know what you think I'm a psycho I
tried to think about what Newcastle
Brown this is definitely Newcastle an
issue this is amazing
it's good right this is amazing so great
story about these guys so early 90s no
one gave a [ __ ] about small brewery
beers like from American breweries just
like in the early eighties no one gave a
[ __ ] about hip hop you don't mean a
scream like that right I understand but
these guys came together these guys open
this brewery and they couldn't sell
enough of their beer in New York but
yeah so the invited Sierra Nevada and
some other breweries to put their beer
on the same truck so that they could
deliver together and have some economies
of scale Wow and then now they're both
kicking ass kicking ass yep I think Bear
is the most common drink to connect
people because you can see a rich person
yeah you see a poor person and they can
both be at the airport in the same bar
and they might want the same exactly so
that's the reason why I like beer yeah
yeah levels you out today we built our
own DIY remixes of these beers yes but
your pass been pretty complex you've
woven allotted for yes art forms into
each other you're right no you know that
we're at seams just what they're known
for is classic craft mixology and we are
gonna go hang with the proprietor Pamela
as I sent her in advance your some of
your favorite ingredients both beverage
side and culinary side is it pistachio
and I'm tellin all right I love a stem
but she's gonna put a bunch of stuff
together okay okay and she's gonna read
after you your palate all right I'm in
don't tell me kid hip-hop legend what
what podcast power the host of a
different kind of food ship for a
drinker as multi-faceted my guests north
we had to mix things up and create a
never-before-seen beer cocktail that's
layered complex and a little offset to
complement the mellow bitterness of 60
Minute IPA our mixologist girl Pamela
was
it's ER and Hennessy pistachio mud lemon
juice and sugar to create a perfect
storm of Nori's favorite things all in
one left this is the classic Sheen remix
wrap tight beer can be just you know
mixed like one on one you guys are
making some like [ __ ] tens l if you
think so we can also make beer cocktails
which is huge right now never heard of a
bit of cocktail no you can't say that
after today my beer cocktail virginity
is yours okay I've been waiting for this
note so we're gonna start the first
degree which is just some citrus this is
fresh lemon juice a little bit of Kings
syrup just a touch a sweetener I hear
you like pistachio did they tell you
they did tell me that that's definitely
almost pistachio yeah so we actually
have a pistachio milk you and I have a
shared love of cognac so we're adding a
derivative of Hennessy VSOP we're gonna
be adding a bit of the abductors chat a
60-minute with beer cocktails which is
something called rolling or throwing a
cocktail and the whole point is to
lengthen the drink and to pull all the
ingredients in flavors together but not
to lose the bubbles just for aesthetics
there's some dehydrated lemon and then
pistachio right so green it up some
pistachio on top I'm not a lot she is
good this is gonna be for you guys
[Music]
so good you realize that this beer in
there yeah but you don't actually off
the first sip you don't think that the
thing is you think that you're actually
gonna [ __ ] down the beer comes later I
love the mix of the the citrus the
nuttiness from the pistachio and the
cognacs just like in the middle of it
it's the heart but it's not everything I
hope I did justice to to the beer you
know it did this still straw that's
what's up you win
[Music]
thank you so much my brother oh my god
this guy this guy told me everything he
taught me the world I am now a beer
ologist yes you are and she's a
mixologist
she's a mixology conquer the world Oh
3x3 god dammit
you